this is I picked this game from a 2000
World Championship between Vladimir
Kramnik and Kasparov Garry Kasparov this
match was won by Kramnik and
surprisingly because he was you know
considered the underdog and as much but
he played very well and I think he
didn't even lose any games yeah so he
won the first game and then yeah he he
played very well overall and just won
the match convincingly so let's take a
look at this opening d4 Knight f6 c4 e6
93 B should be forged what is the name
of this opening nimzo-indian defense so
it's a very interesting and solid
opening choice by black and now he chose
to move III so what's the name of this
variation any ideas
one of the main lines this is the this
move and Quincy q classical and III is
called the Rubinstein Rubinstein
variation now he castles Bishop d3 d5
Knight f3 the mainlines c5 castles
see takes d4 he takes d4
dee takes in for taking on c4 Bishop
takes c4 and now he play the move b6 I
like this system for black as well I
played it myself the idea is to go
Bishop d7 and very solid position for
black no weaknesses
I play the move Bishop g5 activating the
bishop and pinning it is activating it
and pinning it now this should be seven
developing the bishop and not putting
pressure on f3
rook to e1
developing the rope on open file and now
night be d7 9b d7 and now the last piece
that needs to be developed well also
Queen is will rock c1 is played so this
is still t buddy so the ball players are
following theory and now a very short
move here played by chrome neck so let's
see if you can find a smooth white to
play Bishop is under attack on c4 and
yeah if you go Bishop b3 it's possible
but you're a little bit retreating so
what can you do here that you can
combine defense of the bishop with an
offensive attempt Alex
Windi three and if Bishop takes f3 I
think your queen is going to be
overworked because you cannot take back
you can lose the bishop it's going to
get overworked it's going to get
overworked combined defense of the
bishop with some offensive attempt yes
they should be through the possibility
is a possibility yes but that's again
defense a little bit you're going to
defense a little bit Queen to b3 Queen
to b3 okay activating your queen and
attacking the bishop attacking the
bishop now the best move is bishops III
actually look take c3 h6 questioning the
bishop bishop goes back on h4 and now
Bishop d5 is one possibility or Queen e8
is another way to play to unpin the pin
I think these positions are very close
to equal maybe small advantage for white
but he didn't play Bishop c3 which was
surprising and he played a move Bishop
e7 does turn out to be a blunder
question mark now why the question is
why is this a question mark what's the
idea here yes but that runs in 295
immediately your queen is going to be on
three that's the problem
your queen is going to be on pre the
movements are difficult want to find
because we don't think about doing that
move right now but your Bishop e6 idea
is going to work but maybe a little bit
later okay you need to do something
first
and then perhaps it will work yes now if
I was already suggested but the 95 just
takes 95 he just takes and maybe the 97
back you know it's playable position
what else what else can you think of
your idea Bishop e6 think about it how
can you make this idea work how can you
work this out this idea because when we
go Bishop e6 right away
the problem is Queen a6 check it goes
rook f7 and then we don't have a jump
haha
yes Bishop takes f6 that's what he
played first so he's exchanging the
bishop to give himself denied g5 move so
Knight xf6 was played Bishop f6 Knight
b5 is very unpleasant
because now hitting the pollen a7 and
threatening 96 okay goes here 96 comes
in and now it's Adam it's very difficult
to get that nine out of there
look at that tactic if takes Bishop is 6
so that's why it goes Knight takes f6
now it goes Knight xf 6 + which idea
going to work now now Bishop takes works
perfect attacking the rook as well so he
takes check if you go to cap 7 then I
have 95 ok so that's why he has to go
here because if it goes rook f7 Knight
g5 attacking this if you go seer you
just take and take okay
so he goes King h8 and now
take the bishop free bishop take the
free Bishop Knight to g5 you only gonna
win exchange if you can out of seven now
Bishop takes f3 hoping to escape hoping
to escape to a draw here by ruining the
structure structure now is ruined now
what you going to do if you take the
Queen rook ft8 and then you will lose
your central pawn and yes you will have
extra pawn but your pawn structure will
be very weak okay so something like this
or
sorry
maybe even this way capture and takes
and the pawns are weak okay so some
chances for draw so that's why Gramlich
went GTA except right away so it's not
afraid of this move but now it's very
concrete move here you need to play very
concrete here because again the king is
a little bit weak and pawn structure is
ruined
so which active move he played yet he
won this move in twenty five this game
in twenty five moves so a very strong
game here yes it's possible but what
else you have what else you can try to
do ninety four it's an idea but then he
might take Knight takes e4 and if you
under both the plants f2 pawn hangs rock
and a queen any other active ideas you
see correct decision yes that's like
that's what he played activating the
knight attacking the Queen and not
really interested in winning this pawn
because you see Queen f4 was another
interesting idea cuz part of 50 pawn on
b2 Queen f4 is interesting but white is
still better after 96 that's where the
knight wants to go is not interested in
grabbing some pawns Queen f3 and now
just take and King G escapes
there's no perpetual here I mean this
white is up exchange you should be able
to win this okay so that's why he took
the pot on B Q and now what are you
going to do
make sure you don't blunder now okay
make sure you don't blunder rooked xc8
correct looked xc8 hahaha and now which
piece is going to come in into the game
that we will be trying to bring this
piece in as well right
to create threads yes we're excellent
decision again see a lot of people would
get tempted about taking pawns like
Paulo might say but that's not you you
don't get tempted by that you want to
bring the knight in because you're going
to try to win this game by an attack now
he goes rook b8 now
now what are you going to do pause pause
don't rush night it best defense was
actually look eight this was the best
defense okay there is a difference but
he played here so which move Queen
Knight x98 it's an idea but you don't
think he played ninety eight because
this Nigeria response that's worth
protecting
yes Knight f7 check remember check the
King first he goes here now you remember
the smother mate idea put him into that
smother mate idea so you can do it how
you gonna do it which move you need to
set up that mechanism he's got it
excellent yes now he can play five or
you can play rook FA hit bedrock f8
which is losing but we can look at a
trial as well so let's see the finish
first do you see the finishing touch now
nine eight six and here and here
III the moral champion wouldn't blunder
this mother made so you play the move he
he you know he sees that he's not going
to just blunder that right here you can
force the resignation in two moves who
is gonna get that huh
who is gonna find that resignation idea
and what's the follow-up okay yes yes
but remember when you want to trap the
rook with sometimes you put a piece
there and reduces his scope not too
difficult now check he has to go here
now the rook is getting trapped now not
so many squares to go to and who is
going to find the finishing touch it's
clear it's evident now yeah yes show me
a way how to protect the rook Knight d7
not going to do it Queen takes if you
take Queen takes if you go here
beautiful finish right that you were
trying to do it background checkmate and
if it goes now rook g8 what you're going
to do smother Bravo there you go okay
that's what happened now after night the
Queen d7 he resigned in a view of the
following variations in a view of those
following variation see resigned yes
any questions
came to Jade here
here
oh here 9s o ki g8 one second aha
Oh King goes to g8 ah no it doesn't 96
threatening checkmate threatening
checkmate only way to stop those
checkmate is to play rook f7 correct and
now check so it's a knight transfer what
is your question this little tough one
that's Tuffy yeah and King G check this
is the winner Allen okay so now you saw
how he managed to play this position now
I have a couple of positions that I want
to set up for you some endgame positions
and see if you can find a good plan to
win okay some end games we're going to
do so let's start with this position
first now you're playing from the blacks
perspective here okay you are under a
check and you need to make a decision
here okay so this is a game between
Fisher Fisher is actually Wyatts Fisher
Robert Fisher is white against the
Russian rap master holmov 1965 played in
Havana Cuba so now what is the correct
move here let me flip the board so
you're playing from black what is the
correct move here for Grandmaster holmov
as you see he has a positional advantage
because he has positional advantage
because of the protected passed pawn on
c4 so what to do here what is the move
that he played that helped him to defeat
Fischer here you have couple of options
take your time take your time and make
sure you find the right idea
we have a couple of places you can go to
here with the kink kink f7 playing it
safe but then he goes kinky for he is
centralizing his king that's playing a
little bit safe not playing for the
maximum advantage here what is the
correct decision that needs to be played
to play for maximum advantage yes
absolutely absolutely King if I'm needed
it's the little bit risky but that's
needed okay in order to play for when
you need that so he play rook g7 Fischer
activating the bishop now be sure to be
the eight what is the threat do you see
the threat now for black what is black
trying to do now by playing Bishop e8 he
created a nice threat here that he wants
to go with it what's the threat there
should be six attacking yes now in this
position Fischer played through p7
but it was worth to try this move I
think look a 2g one and I it looks like
it's losing because of this move but in
fact there should be six is a huge
blunder here we can point out why it's a
huge blunder should be more hands should
be more hands I think by now why is this
a huge blunder huh
yes in the back look at that see that's
that's why Allen here when I go there
okay well don't worry but you have a way
out of this look you start out with this
check you start out with this check take
take and what's the winning move rook
belongs where everybody put file check
pick up the pants pick up the game yeah
perfect so that's why I didn't win that
that's why fishermen through p7
preventing with this move now continue
play good continue play good here rook
belongs wears open fire right so Luke p7
now he played rook b8 now Bishop is
pinned so he goes up g7 so you can move
that so now a forest plate now the
following plan is very interesting that
grandma circle move is trying to do here
let's see if you can find the following
plan here for him
if the bishop moves the problem is rook
F a check so it kind of wants to keep
the bishop here but he also wants to
create a threat some kind of threat
yes that's a possibility
you could do that but Bishop is okay for
now it's shutting down the rook so he's
going to capture capture and maybe
activate a rook and pin you a little bit
what else do you see here what else can
you mention here huh that's what she
just said
taketake here you getting pinned up now
well it's not bishop move okay okay it's
not a bishop move what about this square
huh
that's a weak square right you would
love to put the rook there right and say
check how are you going to arrange that
huh how are you going to play like the
Russian Grand Master yes excellent see
that was a good hint for you now you got
it
takes takes an official capture the pawn
rook AAA it was a better move but it
still it still loses the game after h4
and rook g3 but he took and now what is
the correct move here don't trash
so there is no longer a threat of Ruka
fate that means which piece we can
activate since there is no longer that
threat yes
Bishop h4 Bravo now you threaten check
and take so you went back to e1 now we
know rooks belong where seventh rank
check King f1 rook is under attack you
don't have time to take my bishop so
what you what you are going to do is you
got to put this so nice square yes to
now Bishop g1 is failing to rook f3 it's
like meat yeah big trouble cannot go
here takes so it has to go King g1 if it
doesn't want to get mated yeah see how
good the position of the King is here
it's not going to get checked it's like
very active and it's hidden now
the rook is under attack what you're
going to do with the rook you want to
get some temples to attack this piece
right yes rookie two attacking the
bishop now twice bishop b6 and now
push push past pounce remember they
meant to be pushed and that's what you
do in past pants meant to be pushed see
to and roopd one is coming so he goes
king f1 attacking your rook
now another attack the final move was
nice - he simply went back where yeah
absolutely threatening check again and
Fisher resigned here and this was one of
the rare games that where he lost an
endgame you know he was outplayed so
King g1 played he didn't play this move
his opponent but if he plays kim ji-won
what is the correct move now to remain
the rook here to keep that rook there
yes bishop g3 protecting it and now he
goes rook c5 and the final touch of this
game yes
push Pawnee correct pushed on with the
threat of rook t1 that is the finishing
touch okay that is the finishing touch
all right excellent any questions so
that was a very interesting game it
started out as a better position for
Grandmaster this is the game Fisher
versus holmov 1965 Havana and yeah this
King f5 you have to go for maximum if
you want to win if you go King F 3 F 7
after king e4 it's not so clear it's not
so clear at all
I mean Bach is maybe still a little bit
better but white will have its own
country play with doubling up the rooks
and trying to create contra play okay so
it's very important not to be afraid
there were some tricks it wasn't
absolutely safe as you saw there were
some ways that you could actually get
made it if you blundered you know but
again with precise calculation of rookie
3 this rook g1 idea doesn't work and you
will simply win this endgame after
update so it was a good example of how
to play this endgame and how to use your
King as a major piece to come in into
the game to control squares to make it
more difficult for the opponent to do
anything